I have personally never taken an an IQ test
and that's because I never had much motivation
to take one I kind of feel like I have an
idea of my own strengths and weaknesses just
through experience and I never saw much value
and having this measure just try and tell
me what I'm good at at today we're going to
have a look at an IQ test and IQ tests are
supposed to be things that you can't study
for and your results should sort of be the
same no matter what stage in life you're at
it is my personal opinion that if you come
from a mathematical background maybe you will
fare better on one of these test just because
the nature of them seems to involve a lot
of like pattern recognition with things like
rotations Reflections Transformations the
same kind of things you might get really familiar
with if you're doing a lot of geometry stuff
and Math but regardless though this video
im going to show you how a lot of these problems
are supposed to be worked out and maybe that
will provide a few little tricks on how to
identify patterns now mensa is an organisation
that I guess is for people with really high
IQ so to get into mensa so you need to have
scored in the top 2% of the population on
a supervised IQ test one that's officially
recognised I've heard that people in mensa
come from all walks of life some might be
academics and some might have more ordinary
jobs and the organisation is not supposed
to discriminate against anyone and they say
on their website that they identify and foster
human intelligence for the benefit of humanity
maybe that sounds a little bit pretentious
I'm not sure but today we're going to have
a look at something that is a test from the
New Zealand Mensa Society from their website
and the link will be in the description this
is an example of test that people would need
to take to get into Mensa and it's supposed
to give an idea of you know what kind of questions
you could expect this test is supposed to
take no more than 20 minutes and maybe you
want to have a little try yourself by following
the link before I start explaining some of
the answers
this test starts off with some letter and
number based questions but it says that this
type of questions are being phased out so
we're just going to look at the more visual
questions and I have already tried the test
for myself and had a look at their answers
they provide so im giving you insight into
how you're supposed to solve these I'll have
time to go through a few in every section
but I won't be solving every problem here.
for the first one we are being asked to pick
the most logical picture from the right to
continue the sequence on the left
so we need to look at this and setup some
pattern thats happening. At first glance they
look like 3 random different shapes and you
might be tempted to just randomly pick an
answer that you feel looks good sitting next
to those. But try to look at the properties
of the shapes, what's actually going on. One
property of shapes is the number of sides
that is has so here we have just 1 side or
1 line, this shape would have 2 sides, and
this 3. so that gives us a pattern of one
two three then we should look for a shape
with 4 sides and there's just one of those
C A kind of has four lines coming out of the
centre but it's actually their number of sides
not lines coming out of the centre otherwise
3 wouldn't fit so that gives us C.
looking at Number 10 try to figure out what's
staying the same and what's changing throughout
see if we look at this we see this line on
the bottom look like a bit of a clock the
little hand down here is staying on six and
this hand is moving around counterclockwise
around the clock meaning that by the time
we get to the next in the sequence we'd expect
this hand to still be on the bottom and this
one will have moved to be straight so that
would give us B. number 11 shows that sometimes
you need to sort of pick a reference point
and this case it is establishing that the
centre of the image and lines coming out of
the centre are what we're going to care about
so in the first time we have two lines coming
out of the centre and the next one 3, 5 what's
a pattern between two three and five well
this increases by one this increases by 2,
we would expect increase of 3 so it is something
with 8 lines coming out of the centre and
D gets us that answer. number 11 when I did
on my own I got a different answer I was thinking
that we're adding this v-shaped on every time
see we added it here and we added it again
here. If we added a v-shaped on to this one
you get C but the answer that they get is
D and I agree that's better way to do it.
The rest of these problems are very similar
you just looking for like slight changes in
always that these pictures evolve that's consistent
sometimes different elements in the pictures
evolve differently to other elements like
for number 12 we have a L which is going around
the outside of the square counterclockwise
so we expect to end up with a shape like that
in the next one and that sort of independent
from what's happened to the shape in here
which is that and like number 9 the shape
is increasing in side one every time so we'd
expected Square in the next one and a square
and a line like that that would give us D
on to the next page we have a few more of
those examples and then we have complete the
best analogy of pairs by choosing to pictures
two pictures from the right so this means
that were saying like a triangle is to something
as a square is to something else we need to
establish a rule that links these two objects
and also links these two objects in this case
again it's to do with the sides of the shape
so 3 sided shape is to A a square as a Square
is to a pentagon have both increase the side
of the shape by one in each of these examples.
20 there could there be any number of ways
that lives these shapes but we can look at
the answers to get an idea of what's going
on so in the answers we have a rectangle shape
and a square but there's only one of each
of those so that kind of seems like it won't
be consistent because whatever happens here
needs to also happen here what's similar is
that B and C are both triangles types shapes
and how could they relate to these well the
little dash that's in the middle this one
has a vertical dash this one has a horizontal
dash so if the rule is that the rectangle
turns into a triangle and the dash stay the
same then it would make sense for B to go
here and for C to be here.
the next section is more analogy of pairs
except this time they actually give us the
rules that they give us enough to work out
the rule without referring so much to the
answers to do that then we just need to apply
that rule to find out one missing shape. In
this first one I think this one's quite easy
what's happened between here and here well
what happened is this dot has gone missing
in the middle so if we apply that here if
we take away this little square in the middle
we end up with D
then we look at 25 we see that sometimes a
familiarity with angles and rotations can
help us out so between here and here you can
first of all see that these arrowheads seem
to get inverted so this is what we are working
with in the end. if you invert these little
arrowheads looks like we want either B or
D but how do we work out which one of these
well have to figure out what rotation is happening
here and apply it in this case. This little
dash helps you know which way it's been rotating
and actually it's going 90 + a little bit
more it's 135° for me being able to store
that number of 135 in my head when im starting
to think about this helps me out and if I
didn't know know how angles work in a circle
maybe I'd find this a little bit trickier
but if we do 135 degree rotation on this answer
here we'd be going this way will be 90 + a
bit more we would end up like this with our
little arrowheads like this and then if we
invert them which looking at this means taking
them from being out to pointing inwards we
would actually get B
this next page here is about completing the
patterns on these grids we're trying to find
the blank space and then sometimes they've
kind of blacked out one of the spaces I guess
to make it trickier to find the pattern the
first one seems quite obviously to be like
this which is going to be B and then pretty
much all the rest of them have the same sort
of pattern first of all look for shapes that
are similar between rows and columns for example
rectangles circles squares and then down here
circles squares triangles there's often rules
that link all the columns all rows back some
common theme in this example were going to
be expecting a square down here to complete
that row's rule and then what colour is it
going to be well we've only really got full
information on this middle line and I looks
like there will be 2 white and one back so
we can expect this one to be white cos we've
got a black here and a white here there is
only one answer which is a square that is
white and that would be D
very similar for the next 2, 31 maybe slightly
trickier we have to isolate each element here
so we have shapes lines and then little symbols
looking at the shapes we've got circles squares
triangle so we'd expect a square in here.
let's look at the lines now between this one
and this one we have going on a very small
rotation look like a 45 degree rotation of
this line so 45 and that's consistent between
these two as well it's another 45 min between
this column in this column it's no longer
a 45 degree rotation now it is 90° ok and
that's seen down here too these lines flip
90° so we can expect a 90 degree rotation
between these lines and here that would give
us some lines like this now we need to look
at the little symbols and between this column
in this column from looking at the square
and the star looks like the shapes are moving
clockwise around the corners and they move
one spot at a time however that changes again
between the second and third columns and we
see that the shape now moves and advances
two corners at a time so it advances all the
way down to here we see that as well with
the circle goes to here so if we advance the
star two places 1, 2 we expect our star up
here that would give us answer C
some of these visual patterns I feel like
can be slightly overwhelming to first look
at because it seems like there are so many
random moving parts but try to isolate you
know each element and what it's doing sometimes
it's working completely independently of other
elements it does seem a bit strange that we're
using these very abstract little puzzles to
try and measure a something as complex as
intelligence our world is so complex and you
know we're trying to measure our interaction
with it through these little patterns and
does that mean that everything in life comes
down to just recognise patterns well maybe
that is a part of it maybe if being able to
see how something involves and works out from
a little bit of evidence you've got already
maybe that is what intelligences is that you
can identify those things I guess I'm not
totally sold on IQ tests but it's interesting
to just have a little look at what they're
asking us I guess with these sorts of test
if you do well It can be a good way to make
you feel good to sort of fluff up your ego
a little bit and if you do poorly then you
can always say these things are sort of subjective
you know how can you measure intelligence
with a test there is a few more patterns here
that you can try there's one more on the following
page if you found it a breeze maybe you even
want to try out for Mensa but I hope it was
a little bit of insight into what's going
on here and thanks for watching
if you were curious about this shirt it is
some merch from blackpenredpen he makes awesome
math videos and I'll put a link in the description
to his channel and I'd encourage you to check
him out you probably can't wear the shirt
to an exam but it's pretty cool one